Nick how are you I'm good Conan I'm I do
have to say I miss being behind a
curtain right now talking to a teamster
hearing that intro and then walking out
and awkwardly waving at a studio
audience who is mildly pleased to see me
so this is uh I'm doing but otherwise
I'm doing well I'm very happy to be
communicating hey you know what I want
to do before I forget which is I got
invited to I think like seven satyrs
virtual satyrs for Passover I'm curious
did you participate in a Passover Seder
I did actually we did one last night
with a at 3:30 p.m. with my family who's
all in New York my sister Dana and her
husband David and their family put on a
whole play the Passover for I Passover
yeah and they all stayed in frame and it
was like watching a it was like watching
a great production of the exodus from
Egypt yeah and the original Exodus was
done on zoom' I'm told
yes what did you do on your end um I
made this thing called Carosa which is a
corrosive charoset corrosive yeah there
you go
there it is you are an Irishman who's
been in enough writers rooms with Jews
[Laughter]
gorgeous so Carosa tis like apples
walnuts some some wine
cinnamon and it sort of chopped up into
a fine thing and it's supposed to
symbolize the bricks that the Jews
enslaved in Egypt used to build the
pyramids and you mix it with more or
although as Hebrew had been Mahal can
you know oh very good
with just like horseradish and you make
a little sandwich out of it you eat it
on matzah I so I made that last night to
impress my family like look at what a
good Jewish boy I am and then I woke up
this morning and my eyes are coming back
but I had an allergic reaction to the
walnuts yeah I could tell your eye even
I can tell your eyes look a little like
bugged out yeah
either bugged out I so I had an allergic
reaction to making charoset at an online
Seder which may be one of the more
Jewish things said on earth today